pretty much anything can beat Biden
these days from bicycles
to staircases to multi-syllabic words
as the president showed us yesterday
during a speech in honor of national
poetry Day always one moon like a silent
drum tapping at every rooftop and every
window on every in every County
countries let me start this over again
I'm getting so intimidated by being here
and always one moon like a silent drum
tapping on every rooftop and every
window of one country a county county
all of us facing the Stars hope a new
constellation waiting for us to map it
waiting for us to name it together if
the country is waiting for Joe Biden to
name it and America is in even worse
shape than I thought that it was